Here's Doctor James Dobson with Family Talk.
Why do some children love to work and others get depressed just thinking about it?
Well, some of the difference can be traced to temperaments...
...but generally speaking, children learn what they've been taught.
Some well-meaning parents think childhood should not be encumbered by work.
Life is hard enough, they conclude, without making children do what they don't want to do.
But if children aren't at least exposed to work at a young age,...
...they may fail to develop the persistence and initiative required for successful living.
Author Jean Lush says household chores should be divided into two general categories:...
...routine contributions and extra jobs.
The routine, such as making beds or emptying trash cans,...
...should be part of the children's unpaid responsibilities.
But extra jobs should provide opportunities to earn additional money.
Furthermore, children learn by imitation so concentrate on hands-on instruction.
Instead of saying, "Go make your bed!"...
...do the task with the child.
Working with an adult is the most enriching form of play for a child if it's handled right.
Find things to laugh about.
If you nag or constantly correct your child, he'll build up a negative attitude toward work.
Of course, teaching children how to work is itself difficult for parents.
But the benefits of your time and effort would be evident...
...when your child is productive and responsible later on.
Doctor James Dobson with Family Talk.